there are actual journalists I this is
so spectacular this is so absolutely
spectacular Rebel news which is up in
Canada it's one of the non-state funded
journalist outfits and I can actually
say journalists without going like this
up in Canada they do great great work
Ezreal event who has been on the show
many times and he's a friend of mine and
a great guy he is out there with the
team in Davos on the ground asking these
guys questions here's Avi yemeni who's
one of the guys at Rebel uh basically
hunting down borla and watch journalism
in action this is journalism completely
uh against what we just saw with that
Bloomberg hack Mr borla can I ask you
did you know that the vaccines didn't
stop transmission how long did you know
that without saying it publicly thank
you very much I'm sorry to that question
I mean we we now know that the vaccines
didn't stop transmission but why did you
keep it secret
you said it was 100 effective then 90
then 80 then 70 percent but we now know
that the vaccines do not trans stop
transmission why did you keep that
secret have a nice day I won't have a
nice day until I know the answer why did
you keep it a secret that your vaccine
did not stop transmission
is it time to apologize to the world sir
to give refunds back to the countries
that poured all their money into your
vaccine that doesn't work your
ineffective vaccine
are you not ashamed of what you've done
in the last couple of years Jeopardy
apologies to the public sir
those are great people right there so I
want to give credit to Israel Levant of
course who was asking the initial
questions and that's Abby yemeni who's
doing the follow-up there you know
what's so interesting too so this borla
guy can go on these ridiculous corporate
press things and just spread more
nonsense and he has these these fake
hack journalists who sit there and don't
acknowledge anything bad that happened
but oh but you can do more and we can
give you more of our attention and and
and money and pay and all of that stuff
and are literally our bodies if borla
believed in anything he has sold to us
in these last three years why wouldn't
he have just stopped for one second like
if you if you created a product a
vaccine that is working that is doing
anything remotely close to what you said
why wouldn't he have just stopped for
one second and said uh thanks for the
question Ezra that's actually pretty
easy uh the efficacy is this uh it was a
little bit off perhaps what we thought
it was going to be but but he can't he
can't so that's actual journalism
[Music]
foreign
[Music]